the first international civilian flight
to leave afghanistan since the u.s led
withdrawal has now landed in doha more
than 100 passengers were on board the
flight including u.s and german citizens
the flight to doha comes as the taliban
consolidate their grip on power less
than a month after they seized control
of kabul
another flight bound for qatar is
expected to depart on friday
but many thousands of afghans remain
desperate to leave the country fearing
for their future
under taliban rules
all right we want to bring in france
marty now he's a journalist based in
kabul one of the few western observers
still left in the country good evening
to you franz can you tell us
what was among those those people who
were able to leave kabul today what did
they have that allowed them to get on
that plane and leave the
country it's not 100 verified but
apparently it was all like um
passport holders from foreign countries
mainly u.s citizens
uh some uh canadian and british citizens
i was told uh among them possibly
many um
afghans who got naturalized citizenship
and this was a special flight so this
was a charter flight
and this was based on an apparent
agreement between these nations and the
taliban
to repatriate them so we're talking
about foreigners who had the correct
papers they were allowed to leave what
about afghan citizens who want to leave
the taliban have said that they will
allow and they have said this several
times that they will allow afghans who
have all the right travel papers to come
and go as they please at the moment this
is a rather hypothetical question
because like today this was a first
flight but this was under a special
agreement so this wasn't like a regular
flight
when regular
international flights uh commercial
flights will again start is at the time
still not clear um it might take several
more days and then there will be the
test how easy uh afghans with with the
right papers can leave for example the
land border crossings are currently
only partly open and neighboring
countries
don't let afghans in
except when they have a visa but it
doesn't seem to happen like often so
this test is just yet to come in front
you know we focus a lot on the people
who are trying to leave who are leaving
the country but
the taliban you know it has 40 million
afghans now that it has to govern and it
is facing lots of crises isn't it
humanitarian crises
indeed uh there's a huge problem and
many afghans that i talked to also say
that like their biggest worry is the
unemployment unemployment was already
before like a huge problem but now it
has like increased even more um funds of
the former government have been frozen
and the the taliban have to now deal
with a
um swiftly deteriorating economic
situation and at the time being there's
like no sign
what or how they they will do anything
against it so this will be like one of
the the biggest tests and one of the
biggest thing to look out uh how the
economic situation of afghanistan will
go forward
okay journalists france marty with the
latest tonight from kabul france as
always thank you
well there is mounting concern about the
fate of women under the taliban those
who've staged rallies demanding the
right to work and to go to school have
been met with violence many fear a
return to repressive rule
[Music]
it takes courage to protest openly
against the taliban especially for women
yet these female protesters in mazay
sharif refuse to be silenced
we demand the creation of secure jobs
both for men and women and the right to
participate in politics for women
the right for women to be selected and
elected for leadership positions and the
right to private ownership
the right for women to work in the
judicial and legal sector and the right
to freedom of speech
but the taliban's strict gender rules
have already started to affect everyday
life
female students returning to university
on the first day of lectures after the
summer break
found they'd been separated from their
male classmates
and now this curtain
it's horrible but we have no choice
it's absurd everything has stopped for
us many people have left i feel lonely
and desperate
when the taliban ruled afghanistan 20
years ago women's rights were severely
curtailed
women were not allowed to work they were
banned from education and only allowed
in public fully covered and accompanied
by a male chaperone
this time around the hardline islamists
have been keen to portray themselves as
more moderate in their first press
conference after taking power their
spokesman promised women's rights would
be honored within the norms of islamic
law
though he failed to elaborate on what
exactly this would mean
many women in afghanistan expect to
return to the dark days of the taliban's
first reign
we spoke to a student at the american
university of afghanistan in kabul
you know like when
when someone is
dreaming for for a better life and
working for 21 years to to
to just reach the dream and suddenly in
one night everything just damaged
just imagine
and now i i might still feel like i'm in
a room where
only there is a darkness
no hope for a better future or no hope
for a lot
this is the feeling that i really have
welcome
that feeling of hopelessness is far from
unwarranted two weeks ago the taliban
told working women to stay at home for
security reasons a measure they said was
temporary
but many fear this is just one of many
steps towards a society in which women
will ultimately be deprived of their
fundamental rights and freedoms
and all but erased from public life
well a senior taliban official has said
that women will be forbidden from
playing cricket or possibly any other
sport because their participation and
i'm quoting here is not necessary now
since the taliban assumed power in
afghanistan the country's women's
football team has been disbanded with a
large number of former players evacuated
to australia on wednesday a taliban
spokesman said female participation in
any events that expose their bodies will
be forbidden
qriket australia has responded saying a
men's cricket match between afghanistan
and australia which is scheduled for
november will be cancelled if the
taliban go through with the ban
it's not a surprise because we knew it
when the when when taliban took away the
country that is like
the first instant action for us for me
especially was to
to get our players as as many as
possible get out of the country because
we knew them we know them they have been
always like this and they will never
change of course they are changed
in terms of like how they communicate
with media but
with what with their action and what
they are doing and especially the
announcement that they are made
they have never been changed that they
don't see a woman in in participating in
any um any activities in society they
don't they just want to vanish women um
they don't see women as part of the
population